I'm Jad Abumrad Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab or topic today where its
power of words of language. Okay,
so Nicaragua 1970s that's where
our next story starts. You with me?
So imagine you're a kid that's deaf
in Nicaragua at this time, born deaf,
or are born deaf, born deaf.
You've always been deaf and you're the
only one in your family that's deaf.
So you're in this situation
where everybody's talking,
their mounts are moving,
you can't hear it and you don't know
sign language cause no one's taught you.
There was no deaf school in
Nicaragua than nothing. Okay?
No deaf education of any
kind. So if you were this kid,
all you've really got are a couple
of gestures, really. Crew gestures.
You've worked out to talk
to your family and friends.
But beyond that you're cut off
Blake Ildefonso, the guy we met
at the beginning of this show,
except in Nicaragua in the
70s there were hundreds,
maybe thousands of these LD
fans. Those really? Yeah.
But then everything changes in the late
seventies hopes of Mosa who was the wife
of the then dictator established a
new school for special education.
I think she had someone in her family
who had a disability, not deafness,
but the school would include deaf people
and that says psychology professor and
Singhouse was the first cause. Now
instead of deaf kids scattered about,
they were together in the same room.
There were 50 deaf kids in that first
entering class, preschool to sixth grade,
the late seventies for most of them.
This was the first time they'd ever met
another deaf person before the world was
going on around them and everyone was
all talking and they were cut off from
that and suddenly for the first time they
were all there and they were what was
happening and they were what
there was to talk about,
but they didn't have a way of talking.
These are 50 different kids who'd never
learned a language and had 50 different
sets of like rudimentary
gestures that they used to. Wow.
That must have been like 50 people with
50 different ways to try and ask for
breakfast or say they want to go
outside. I mean nothing was shared.
It's not like the teachers were
using sign in the classroom.
Everything in the classroom was
Spanish, which none of them knew,
copying it into their notebooks.
A lot of it was going right over their
heads who at the beginning things were
completely confusing,
but they're riding on the bus for an
hour every day and they're playing out of
recess for an hour every day and they're
getting together at the park and no one
knows how it happened. Like maybe one
of the kids who was very charismatic,
he invented a sign for safe ball, then
told it to another kid who was very,
you know, socially active. And that
second kid then spread the sign.
However it worked over time,
the signs that these 50 kids used
started to converge into a common system.
And when you step back from
it all, what that means,
they created a language
[inaudible]
they, it's, they didn't just
take it from somewhere else,
they couldn't take it from somewhere else.
They created own. But how unusual is that?
Like this has happened with
languages all over the world,
but not while people were watching it.
So you're saying this is the first time
we've been able to watch a language
being born? Yeah.
Wow.
And for the last 20 years, that
is what Anne has been doing.
She's been going to Nicaragua
to that school and watch it.
So, um, oh, you want to describe that?
So I may have gotten recording of this,
but when you arrive at the school,
the buses come around,
the kids are all screaming and leaning
out the windows and siding to each other
and the kids pile out and they line up
in rows on the basketball court that's in
the center of the school yard.
And they all sing the national him
[inaudible]
and the deaf kids all sign the national
hem and they all have one hand over
their heart and sign with the other
hand while the, the hearing kids sing it
and visited the school for the first
time in 1990 about 10 years after it was
formed, she'd been working at the
time with a linguist named Judy Kegel,
studying basic linguists
type stuff. Right.
Trying to figure out how the verbs work
and whether they have agreement with
their grammatical objects. And along
the way her and a collaborator,
jetty pyres stumbled into something really
surprising about the power of certain
words there to set it up.
When she got there the
first time in two Nicaragua,
those original 50 kids who'd invented
this thing had grown up already.
And there were these younger generations
of kids coming in behind them,
growing up with the language,
using it, inventing new signs.
And at a certain point she got curious
to just compare the original signers,
the older kids to the younger kids.
Yeah. In terms of how they sign,
we show everyone this.
Well, one minute cartoon about
this guy who's trying to fly.
He sees a bird flying and he puts all
these feathers on his body and clouds up
to the top of a mountain,
flaps his arm and jumps up
and crashes on the ground.
So she showed deaf kids
of different generations,
this cartoon and asked them pretty
simply to describe what they saw.
Just describe it in sign,
describe the whole story.
The differences were
striking. Um, first of all,
so I'll just show you an example of
each year of vaping. A movie here.
This is a first cohort
signer talking about,
she got out her laptop
and showed me some video.
First of this woman in
her hair, her forties,
with dark hair and a colorful tee shirt.
She was one of the original signers.
And when you see older signers like her,
describe this guy who's trying to fly,
it's really spastic.
It's almost like they become the cartoon
and she's flapping her hands just
socially. So moving all around,
a lot of full body movements.
She's talking about someone
who's moving in a crazy way.
She's going to be moving in a crazy
way. And then she showed me a
young kid who was about eight,
the backwards cat.
So here's Sylvester and now he talks
about the manner when he described the man
jumping and then falling,
it was all in the wrist.
All the movement is now in the
hand and it's a very stylish,
you know, they're trimming these
signs down. But more to the point,
there was one thing she noticed
that was really unexpected,
had nothing to do with movement, couldn't
help noticing that they, that people,
different people in the community talked
about different things in this story.
The older signers tended to describe all
the events in this story and only the
events and the younger kids,
they would talk about the guy's feelings
that this guy was trying to fly,
wanted to fly, but failed
the kids. She says,
just seem to be better at
thinking about thinking,
thinking like other people's
thinking. So Anne and Jenny decided,
let's take all the different
generations of deaf kids, 40 year olds,
30 year olds, 20 year olds, 10 year olds.
Let me test them on how well
they can think about thinking.
So what they did was they showed everybody
a comic strip different from before.
This one was about two brothers.
There's a big brother who was playing
with a train and then little brother is
like wanting to play with the training
and the big brother's playing with the
tray and then the big brother puts it
under the bed and goes into the kitchen to
eat a sandwich.
And maybe before he goes, he looks
at the little brother and says, Hey,
don't touch my train, don't touch
it. And then little brother,
while the big brother is out of the room,
takes the train out and
hides it in the toy box.
And then the big brother comes
back and the question is,
where's the big brother going
to go to find this train?
Is he going to look under the bed
or is he gonna look in the toy box?
Well, he's going to look under the bed.
Yep. Because it's as far as he knows,
that's where he left it.
Yeah. He didn't see it moved.
And if you ask kids over the age of five,
most of them would say he's going to look
under the bed because that's where he
left it. And he doesn't know that
it's been moved to the toy box,
but here's the thing. When she asked
the older signers, they would say,
oh look in the toy box. Really
they would pick the wrong one.
These are 35 year olds. 35
year olds would get this wrong.
They would fail this task. Yeah,
seven out of eight she says,
and then all of the younger signers
that we worked with past at this point,
she's just confused
like why would this be,
why can't the older people pass
this simple test? You know,
that involves thinking about someone
else's thinking, what's going on here.
And then in a career tour you might
have something to do with certain words
because the older signers,
they don't really have that many
words for the concept of thinking.
I mean they have mainly just one
side pointing at your forehead. Yeah.
Basically you just point at your
forehead with your index finger.
By the time you get to the younger kids,
they've got tons of words
for thinking things like,
I know something and I know
that you don't know it.
I know something and I know you do know
it. They've a signed for understand,
believe, remember, forget
how many roughly were there?
10 or 12 wow. So from 30 years
we go from just a couple,
two of them from like knowing
and not knowing. Right? 12 yeah,
and somehow that makes all the difference.
She says the more of these
think words you've got,
the more you can think. Am I right to
say that you're tiptoeing toward that,
that you maybe you don't
want to go there all the way.
I'm trying to think that I guess I don't
think it's so simple that you could
just go in and say, Hey,
I'm going to teach you 10 signs today
and now suddenly you're going to have
better cognitive capacity.
But you are saying though that the verb
think [inaudible] is somehow implicated
in my ability to think
about your thinking. Right.
[inaudible]
thinking about thinking,
understanding how other people understand.
That's something that having
language makes you better at.
There are certain words she says that
don't just give you a name for something.
Somehow they give you access to a concept.
It would otherwise be really
hard to get or even talk about.
It's really hard to talk about
thoughts without the word thoughts
or what does time without the word
time. It's really freaking hard concept.
These words are like breaches.
Somehow they get you to some new mental
place that otherwise you'd be cut off
from. But that's sad though.
I mean these young kids have something
that the people who actually invented the
language double, but
you went back two years later,
tested the same people and then suddenly
some of them were performing a lot
better than they had the two years
before on the same kinds of tasks.
Do you mean the older signers? Yeah,
they were passing suddenly some
of them were passing. Yeah.
Was that what happened? What
happened in the past two years? Yeah.
Those younger kids grew up and started
hanging out at the deaf association.
Wait, what? So what had
happened in the mean?
So here's the strange
twist of the whole thing.
The Deaf Association is this place where
the older signers would hang out. Yeah.
It's a social club. So they
played chess, do whatever. Well,
it has certain point these youngsters
start showing up, you know,
cause they've graduated and they want
to hang out at the deficit association
too. But they bring with them
all of their new mental verbs,
you know all these words for thinking.
They start using it with the older kids.
The older kids pick it up.
Most suddenly these older
kids are now passing the test.
So there was learning that took place
in adulthood that actually it gives them
new insight into other people's thinking
and motivation and now they can pass
these tasks. That super interesting
story. It's really cool.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and sank Hass is an associate professor
of psychology at Barnard College in New
York.
Hmm.
The thing, of course you want it, you
wonder is a, once you've gotten these,
this new facility in you, there's,
there's a lot of literature about this.
My fear lady is about this
and Philly's about this. Yeah.
It's about a woman who learns uh,
proper English and she can no longer be
a flower girl and come in and garden.
She's family. Yeah. I guess
it is kind of like this.
You want like member that our program
began with the story of Ildefonso, right,
which we heard from
Susan Scholler Ildefonso who's The guy
who for 27 years had no language at all.
So you kind of wonder,
I can tell you that like what happened
to Ildefonso once he got language, right.
And after that first breakthrough where
elephants will realize things have named
Susan ended up leaving for a few years.
So let's see, it was a about four
years, I think, four or five.
Then she decided to write a
book about him. And so I, um,
I went and found him again and he had
language and I could ask him all kinds of
questions.
Were you able then to sit down with him
and ask him about his life and to really
get the sort of his biography
somewhat, somewhat one, um,
area that everyone wants to know about
is what was it like to be language this,
you know, what was going on in his head?
Yeah. And I asked, when I asked him,
I asked and he starts telling me that
was the dark time in his life learning
language.
It's like the lights went on and I tell
him what we know about language and we
want to know what it's like not to have
language and he doesn't want to talk
about it.
But there was a day she says when she was
writing the book and she met Ildefonso
in a restaurant and there he was
sitting with his brother, Mario,
who she'd never met before and she
quickly learned that Mario also was deaf
and the language lists Billy.
So I was shocked and because
I was so amazed going,
I can't believe you have a language
that's brother. That's when, um,
we build upon the son. Well, let, let
me introduce you to some of my friends.
So they get in a car and they drive for
a while. We stopped at this apartment,
we walk into this small little room and
there were these six Mexican men doing
this mine routine. Wait, all of these
guys were like Ildefonso used to be,
they had no language.
We're all born deaf and they didn't
know that they were deaf and what,
what were they doing? One man would
stand up and he would start miming,
he would just start
acting out a bull fight.
So He'd read the bull and he'd be
charging and then you'd be the matador,
and then he'd be somebody in the crowd
watching. And then he would add a detail,
for example, a hatch and they'd swap.
So then another guy would get up to take
over the story and they'd start miming
maybe Mac the matador, describe the hat.
But now the second storyteller
would add a new detail,
like another person with a
pair of glasses or something.
So each one would stand up, take the bull,
fight the same bull fight to a
different point and add a detail.
Exactly, exactly. Oh
my God. In other words,
I would take him maybe 45 minutes to say,
do you remember the time when we were
out of the bull fight and this woman did
such and such? It was like drawing
a picture. Well, let me ask you
a pull it all together. Question.
I was about to think that what a
language is, is a great connector.
But this last story makes me wonder,
these are five men really sharing
and connecting on details.
So is the difference that language makes
just efficiency or does it affect your
heart or your whole body of I
can't tell. I'm not sure anymore.
Well, I'll give you
Ildefonso the answer, which
when I saw him, um, a couple of
years later after this incident,
I asked him about his friends and he
said he couldn't talk to them anymore.
He wasn't willing to go through that
tedious effort of all the miming anymore.
But the interesting thing that he said
was he can't even think that way anymore.
He said he can't think
the way he used to think.
And when I pushed him to ask about what
it was like to be languaged Lis, he,
the closest he ever came to any
kind of an answer was exactly that.
I don't know. I don't remember.
[inaudible]
I think differently now.
Uh,
[inaudible]
Susan Sharla is author of
the book a Man without words.
Go to radiolab.org for more
info. And if you go there,
or if you're subscribed to our
podcast, you'll get this automatically.
But there's a beautiful short film
directed by two really talented guys,
will Hoffman and Daniel Merca
Dante, that is all about words.